knock on wood knock knock episode 4 of
series 10 for Doctor Who and well first
before I get into it I have been failing
through this lately reminder I don't
explore the fray anymore I will be
talking about spoilers as they get into
this and this one was the weakest of the
series so far it's not awful um but I'm
hoping that this that once the whole
series is done that this will serve as
the low point because as far as low
points go
you know the show's been worse but it's
it's not great and it's a shame because
I tend to like the haunted house
scenario type episodes I mean I liked
hide a lot of people didn't seem to love
it that much but I liked that one I like
you know these sorts of scenarios I
think in a lot of ways silence in the
library felt like a haunted house kind
of situation and I like that sort of
setup but I like the doctor in that kind
of setup so it's frustrating for me when
a setup that normally I would go for it
just isn't quite clicking the reasons
are kind of hard to nail down um the
supporting cast in this one is kind of
generic I mean maybe it's because of how
young and generically attractive they
all are but it does feel like they
corralled the the fodder from a slasher
movie and just had them up here in this
instead I mean that says the none of the
acting from the supporting cast is bad
they play off each other well on it but
it's just there's nothing impressive and
maybe that's one of the downsides about
doing a straight kind of haunted house
field kind of story which is that it's
especially set in the modern time
there's not a lot you can bring to the
supporting characters like what I think
of the supporting casts that I really
love they tend to be from you know more
outlandish situations like science or
the library which I mentioned like the
impossible planet or mummy on the Orient
Express I really love those supporting
cats this
not so much and unfortunately we're not
getting as much of the doctor and bill
together in this one and that kind of
has been the strong suit of the series
up to this point I love their dynamic I
love the two of them together and they
are not getting to play off of each
other as much this one so we've kind of
removed one of the strengths of the show
up to this point for this series without
replacing it with anything and the whole
revealed I mean that the buds kind of
skied me but that's only because bugs
skied me a little I wasn't particularly
scared by them I don't think it was
excessively inventive I would have found
it more interesting if they just found a
way for the house just to be absorbing
people rather than oh well it's these
puzzles and they kind of and then they
kind of merge and it's this sense it's
weird it doesn't completely make sense
and I don't always need Doctor Who to
make sense but I need to feel like I can
follow the logic a little bit even if I
can't connect all the dots and this one
I'm like pips that's just kind of odd
I'm really shocked that we didn't
address the sonic screwdriver doesn't
work on would say neither and you know
as a doesn't work on wood now or at
least as an acknowledgement something
for how much wood is in this and it
doesn't come up at all that's weird
one thing I will say about the
supporting cast since they are all
students they all know who the doc well
they don't know who the doctor is but
they they they know him and I oh it's
the doctor so I kind of like that we got
to skip over the introductions and
they're like well who are you and that
that was kind of nice um I think the one
thing that stood out to me as a smart
subversion was with the caretaker of the
house you know that that twist of he's
not the father of of this woman who he's
trying to save he is in fact the child
and I think that's interesting for a
number of reasons I think partly because
we don't it's an inversion of a trope we
see often I think we see parents you
know doing horrible things to save their
children is fairly well-worn territory
at this point children doing horrible
things to save their parents doesn't
come up as much and especially in this
case with a you know a child would have
been very young when they started doing
this awful stuff and you kind of get the
sentence in a little bit of a state of
Arrested Development so while you know
the twist is not particularly shocking I
think it was a smart way to play with
that and to have a little bit of a more
interesting way of tackling that you
know versus the the standard thing that
we're used to seeing in that kind of
situation so that was nice and I
appreciated that but that's kind of the
highlight like I said a lot a lot of it
isn't bad it's just not um there's not a
lot to it there's not a lot elevating it
we're getting a little bit more sense of
whatever is in the ball so it is
absolutely a person so that eliminates
all the theories of you know for people
who thought Gallifrey was in the ball it
is definitely a person there was
somebody playing the piano it's somebody
with a dark side because they seemed to
be interested in hearing the doctor
story once it was mentioned that lots of
young people get killed in it Oh which
makes me want to back up i I don't have
an inherent problem with everybody lives
stories I'm a little bit of a sucker for
them I think they can be overplayed
sometime but I don't have a problem with
that I kind of take issue with this one
though as a oh when the bugs are
reconstructing you know these people I
mean aside from that how does that even
work saying since they're putting
everybody back together it does make me
realize could they not reassemble you
know the people from the 70s from the
50s I mean you know there's there's been
lots and lots of people who have died
here and we're just saving the latest
victims rest urgent nobody cares for
that okay not even gonna mention it
alright it and it just felt I don't know
it felt cheesy it felt cheap and I think
the best everybody lives stories don't
feel cheap and
they feel earned in this one it really
didn't it felt like a toss-up at the end
oh and by the way they're all fine like
they were nice enough I don't think they
deserve to die but really yeah anyway so
getting back to the vault so it's
definitely a person it's a person with
at least a morbid interest if not a
morbid fascination or morbid sense of
humor and that's that's kind of the
little bits of solid information we have
to go on it is interesting to think with
the titles because last time I thought
thin ice was going to be the the Ice
Warriors episode turned out not to be
knock-knock I would assume would have
had more to do with the vault it didn't
I feel like they're trolling us a little
bit with the titles of these episodes
which honestly I'm kind of down for I
kind of like that that level of sort of
subverting the expectations but yeah I
don't have any new particularly you know
deep theory on what's in the vault but
you know as we're getting more
information it's sort of eliminating
possibilities and I'm I'm finding that
interesting as that goes on I'm sure
some people will talk about more
theories down in the comments people
have done so already I haven't responded
to a lot of them because I don't know I
don't want to go down the rabbit hole of
theory of what's in the vault too deeply
largely because I want to be surprised
by it it's one of the reasons that I
avoid you know message boards or whatnot
that really get into fan theory because
inevitably you'll come across one that
is more or less correct and it's like
you spoiled yourself and not I want to
do that I want to give this show the
chance to surprise me I mean of course
if it turns out to be stupid and obvious
I'll call it out on that but failing
that I would prefer to be surprised by
it so we'll see what goes on there what
were your thoughts on this latest
episode of Doctor Who whatever they were
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks kibbe listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher also check out the
punch like a girl podcast also available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]